i would just learn that you do muay thai
yeah you've been doing it since 2017
but if a little bit of background calf
a lot of my brothers
like my brothers you know
been in the streets and [ __ ] like that
i'm the only one out of my brothers that
never been to jail
you know what i'm saying i lost one of
my brothers but the brother i did lose
he was a backyard fighter back in the
day with like kimbo slice and man those
got our five thousand yeah and all the
videos were crazy and that was all in
miami yeah and there was a movie that he
was in called dogfights so i'm just
letting you putting you up on game
and i was also in the movie too but that
was like 12 year old denzel and if you
go on youtube to this day and you look
up like fights like level martinez
versus
watching all those backyard fights
crazy if you look at tree versus uh mike
you're gonna see me there in a white tee
holding the camera up she used to be in
the backyard i used to be in the
backyard like dead ass like i'm not even
gonna sit here a lot to you how would
they organize those things because bro
like my brother would just come in the
room and he'd be like hey you want to
come over here and see me fight and i'll
be like all right
you know i will go there
it will be in perrin in the middle of
paris
it would be a little greenhouse and a
big-ass backyard and they will check you
at the gate to see if you got guns
knives whatever and if you got guns and
eyes whatever you got to go put that
[ __ ] in your car and then you come in
they check kids too
so you going there you know what i'm
saying and there'd be a ring in there at
first it was like a box ring at first
they didn't have no ring at all some of
the videos was just there's just no ring
yeah it was just people crowding around
yeah at first they didn't have a ring
then they had a ring then they had an
octagon then they had a triangle that
was like the final
you know and just being back there and
just watching all these fights you
hearing the beef go down with people and
[ __ ] you know and you're just like yo
what the [ __ ] is going on like you see a
big ass dude like oh my get you [ __ ]
i'm getting like what the [ __ ] like
right yeah i'm 12 years old looking at
all this [ __ ] like yo
this is like some real fighting [ __ ]
like this some real tournament [ __ ] and
i'm watching people get knocked the [ __ ]
out i'm watching blood just
gushing just out of my brother's nose
did your brother ever fight kimbo no
hell no
kimbo was already like in the ufc around
this time yeah okay kim was i mean
but dada was dada and kimbo used to roll
with each other until they kind of fell
out you know what i'm saying
and
around that time it was just dada and
what doubt i was doing in the backyard
but kimbo was before that you know what
i mean so
you know long little kimbo you feel me
so that was kind of the origins of your
that got you interested in learning how
to fight i mean i had to learn how to
fight i had too many brothers to not
know how to fight how many brothers do
you have well one of them passed it was
four of us okay you know what i'm saying
and were you the youngest i'm the
youngest oh yeah i mean you got to learn
how to fight i got to learn how to fight
i was like
like
he's getting bullied outside the house
and getting bullied inside the house so
i had to learn how to fight either way
to go
so in 2017 you take a muay thai yeah um
what do you kind of give us the rundown
on like
just the muay thai [ __ ] because you were
you're very passionate about it well i
don't think a lot of people know cause
you was you're very you know your [ __ ]
man like well when it comes down to muay
thai man i like
well i stopped smoking weed right mm-hmm
and this was back in 2017 i felt like my
life was going to be boring because i
wasn't like smoking right and then i was
like you know i might as well stop
drinking too
so i just looked out i remember i was
doing martial arts with my brothers and
stuff like that when i was younger so
i'm like you know when i find a time
you know if i get enough money i'm just
going to go back into martial arts and i
said that when i first started rapping
and [ __ ] because i stopped doing it
and then
next thing you know i was like oh
there's a muay thai um place right down
the street it was five star martial arts
go there i signed up guy signed me up i
looked at the class and then i went in
the next day started doing it got my
girl to do it
and then um
i just kept doing it ever since and it's
been five years right yeah it's been
five years i can't train not because i
got a torn acl but like
um is it like a do you get belts like
what's like what's your belt level well
in thailand they don't really have a
ranking system okay okay you know what
i'm saying because they've been doing it
since they was kids
they get it on project but that's like
cut off like addresses that's what they
would wear right right before they go
it's like it brings them good luck
but
in
like the ranking system at the school
they will rank it like how they will
rank jiu jitsu you get what i'm saying
you start off white you know you might
get a stripe you might end up at blue
you might get a stripe you might end up
at purple you might get a stripe you
might end up at brown
um and then all the way to black like
brown to black you feel me how serious
people
rank their own schools differently
though how far would you take the muay
thai thing because i don't we know like
uh you know we got a friend d smoke uh
who
was like a semi-professional boxer
before he really started popping as a
rapper so like would you like how far
would you take it i mean i wanted to
compete
to be honest i wanted to compete to see
where my skill level was at you know to
see um if i'm pretty you know
see where i'm at and see where i need to
improve on you know what i mean
but that's how far i was willing to take
it like to do a couple on matches
but
other than that it was just um
i just like doing it for my sanity to be
real it's like it's almost like their
therapy
have you been to thailand yes how was
that thailand is dope this is like very
did you go out there and like watch muay
thai like and it's because you know you
see these like youtube videos like the
muay thai fights in thailand i mean like
lupini stadium stuff like that [ __ ] so
crazy
though yeah i mean i haven't been able
to do that but my boy kashan he been
trying to get me to go to um go back to
thailand and like go to the gyms because
you got to know somebody to have that
connection to the gym just to get in
there yeah i mean it's open but you
gotta i would much rather know somebody
who'd been there before and know these
gyms you know what i'm saying be like
hey just pull up